الجيش الصيني تنظيما تدريبات عسكريه
قتاليه في المجالين البحري والجوي بمحيط
جزيره تايوان واشار الجيش الصيني لان
التدريبات التي تعد الثانيه خلال شهر واحد
تهدف الى التصدي بحزم لما وصفه بالاعمال
لاستفزازيه للقوه الخارجيه والقوه
الانفصاليه في تايوان لحسب التعبيره
جهته اكد الجيش
28 طائره صينيه عبرت الخط الفاصل لمضيق
تايوان خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه وقالت وزاره
الدفاع التايوانيه ان رست الطائرات والسفن
الصينيه حول الجزيره متى امرا شائعا في
الاونه الاخيره وشددت الوزاره على ان
تايوان لا تسعى الى التصعيد ولا الصراع
لكنها ستحافظ على سياده تايوان واوضح
التيفيه نتهامات الجيش الصيني واستفزازاته
غير المنطقيه زعزعه الاستقرار والان في
المنطقه بحسابي وصفها
مدير مكتب الجزيره ناصر عبد الحق ناصر ما
الرسائل السياسيه
لتواتر المناورات الصينيه في هذه المرحله
يبدو ان الصين توجه هذه الرسائل وتكون
حاده في رسائلها خاصه عندما يعني تقوم
هناك وفود دوليه تزور جزيره تايوان
فبالعوده الى اغسطس من العام الماضي
شاهدنا المناورات العسكريه او التدريبات
العسكريه الواسعه التي قامت بها الصين ردا
على زياره رئيسه البرلمان همم رئيس
البرلمان الولايات المتحده نانسي بيلوسي
في ذلك الوقت
وتبيعتها يعني بعد سته اشهر في شهر ديسمبر
الماضي مع نهايه العام كانت هناك مناورات
شبه مماثله والان في وقت قصير تعود الصين
لمثل هذه المناورات الواسعه همم حيث ان
هناك يعني ربما بعض المراقبين يعزوا ذلك
همم بالاضافه طبعا الى التحركات والدعم
الامريكي لما تسميه الصين
الحكومه ذات همم التوجه الانفصالي في
تايوان والصفقات العسكريه التي تقدمها
الولايات المتحده لهذه الحكومه بالاضافه
الى ذلك هناك
وفد برئاسه رئيس البرلمان لجزيره توفالو
التي تقع في المحيط الهندي يقوم الان
بزياره لتايوان ولماذا نذكر هذه الجزيره
لان وزير الخارجيه لهذه الجزيره كان قد
غادر مؤتمرا همم للامم المتحده للمحيطات
همم احتجاجا على لرفض الصين
المشاركه بسبب وجود ثلاث اعضاء تايوانيين
كانوا مشاركين ضمن همم وفد هذه الجزيره
وبالتالي الصين تمطعت كثيرا من زياره هذه
الوفود شكرا لك ناصر